et on fait réagir notre éditorialiste
alexis paulin il est en direct avec nous
bonjour alexis comment est-ce que vous
recevez ces propos du porte parole du
gouvernement à l'instant on bien comme
d'habitude un chaque semaine amène son
lot de de contre
indications d'indications alors on
apprend qu'on a le droit de manger son
poste de travail jusqu'en avril alors je
savais même pas qu'on avait un droit par
rapport à ça mais voilà la guérilla
natale aujourd'hui nous dit que ce pass
vaccinale fonctionne puisque 1 millions
de français ont déjà une injection avant
l'entrée en vigueur du pass vaccinale et
qu' il sera levé quand l'hôpital ira
mieux en gros or l'hôpital il ne peut
pas aller mieux des services d'urgence
continuent de fermer il ya un manque de
bras croissance il y à delhi qui sont
fermés c'est parce qu'on manque de
soignants parce qu'on a nos pital qui
est endémique mans une pandémie
finalement de manque de moyens de
l'hôpital public donc ce que vient de
dire le porte parole finalement c'est
que ce pass vaccinale il est là pour
toujours on ne pourra jamais levé étant
donné l'état de délabrement de l'hôpital
public chaque hiver c'est la même chose
avec le co vite c'est encore pire cinq
cent mille cas hier de covin c'est sûr
que si on continue à tester au prix où
ça coûte 1,5 milliard d'euros par mois
pour tester les tests naso pharyngé
c'est ridicule puisque ça ne veut plus
rien dire un français sur dix a été
testé positif au co vide depuis début
janvier donc on va regarder évidemment
qui est à l'hôpital qui est en
réanimation qui a besoin de soins
critiques et si c'est le cas alors il va
falloir prendre de nouvelles mesures
mais c'est quand même us que d'entendre
le porte-parole dire que grâce au pass
d'axione qui est une mesure liberticide
et inutile on va lever les restrictions
or il n'ya que des restrictions au final
et on voit bien que c'est un narratif
qui s'effondre parce que je pense que le
pari était que la vague au micro-ondes
vert
tombé beaucoup plus rapidement
apparemment il ya un sou variant le béa
2 et là l'entrée en campagne des mâles
de macron se trouve empêcher avec cette
vague au micro puisqu'il devrait se
poser en sauveur et dire je vous libère
mais ça risque d'être plus compliqué que
prévu donc voilà tout est politique très
peu de sanitaires dans cette gestion de
crise depuis le début et là c'est
flagrant avec un porte parole qui ne
sait plus quoi dire si ce n'est on va
changer les chiffres puisque cela ne ne
conviennent pas cinq cent mille cas par
jour c'est inaudible 400 morts à
l'hôpital de kovy de 3000 personnes
hospitalisées c'est un fiasco et patenté
de la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement mais évidemment le partant
on ne peut pas le dire comme ça la
france avec ses devenue la championne
d'europe des contaminations comment est
ce qu'on explique cette envolée des cas
c'est le choix d'une stratégie de la
vaccination à défaut de davantage de
mesure encore plus restrictive comme
c'est le cas chez certains de nos
voisins relâchement général aussi
papa de relations générales star choix
politique c'est le choix de limiter
collective entre guillemets c'est le
choix en fait de dire vous avez le droit
de vous contaminer le pass vaccinale en
fait c'est un droit à la contamination
vous êtes vacciné mais vous pouvez être
contaminé par le comice vous êtes
porteur et vous pouvez contaminé
également vos voisins donc croire que le
pass vaccinale est une protection c'est
totalement illusoire c'est juste un
droit de contaminer les autres donc se
passe de l'accident elle permet à tous
contaminés contaminants de pouvoir aller
où ils veulent et de contaminer qui ils
veulent c'est uniquement ça donc on a
choisi de dire vous aurez tous le covin
vacciner ou non et dans ce grand jeu de
qui l'attrapé qu'il ne l'a pas certains
iront en réanimation et on compte sur le
vaccin pour être utile dans les cas
graves mais la réalité c'est que le
vaccin n'empêche pas la propagation de
l'épidémie on le voit bien en israël et
ailleurs et qu' il ya de nombreux pays
qui commencent à comprendre que la
stratégie vaccinale a ses limites 80% de
la population adulte plus de plus de 12
ans vacciné je ne vois pas qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire de plus et à quoi ça
change qu'est ce que ça changerait et
donc espagne pays bas danemark
grande-bretagne commencent à mettre à la
poubelle les mesure idiote et
liberticide qui ne servent plus à rien
compte tenu de ce qu'est devenue cette
épidémie de covin pour passer à autre
chose parce que sinon c'est la société
qui devient folle c'est l'économie qui
s'arrête et c'est la fin finalement du
lien social et
la vie ensemble comme on pourrait le
faire ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
que certains promoteurs du vaccin
conseil scientifique et d'autres
voudraient accélérer la vaccination des
5 11 ans parce que c'est là un réservoir
d'enfants à vacciner et une proposition
est en train d'avancer des pistes sur la
table c'est pourquoi pas la vaccination
à l'école mais qu'est ce que ça pourrait
changer de vacciner les 5-11 ans compte
tenu du fait que le vaccin n'empêche pas
la propagation du virus et la
contamination donc on est dans une
logique finalement
déconnectée de toute raison où il va
falloir vacciner tout le monde pour dire
qu'on fait quelque chose et que tout le
monde aura le droit d'être contaminés
avec le co vite parce que tout le monde
aura eu sa 2è 3è peut-être quatrième
dose du vaccin mais on est vraiment là
dans un cul-de-sac
épidémiologique et même politique et
c'est bien ce qui fait peur je pense au
gouvernement de ne plus savoir quoi dire
de ne plus savoir qui accuse et on ne
pourra plus accuser les non-vaccinés
d'être responsables de cette épidémie
est de ne pas avoir les moyens de
redonner à l'hôpital les moyens
nécessaires justement pour ne pas
déprogrammer pour pouvoir traiter tout
le monde sans avoir à faire des choix
catastrophique et à s'effondrer sur le
manque de moyens et le burn out de tous
les soignants merci beaucoup pour votre
un regard alexis poulain notre
éditorialiste hrt france